I'm Stuart Varney I'm Harris Faulkner
I'm Brian Kilmeade and this is the Fox
News rundown
Wednesday February 15 2023 and Lisa
Brady they were pandemic lifelines now
Congress wants to know how they ended up
in the wrong hands we were in crisis I
mean in crisis of the highest order
minder and so people weren't too hot
worrying about strings being attached
and saying you know how do you decide
who gets what I'm Dave Anthony
it's been more than a week since turkey
was devastated by an earthquake and we
take you there as they keep searching
for survivors can we find anybody that's
a that's currently alive can we hear
them the dogs will run over the Breville
pile and see if they can detect human
scent and I'm Carol Markowitz I've got
the final word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
this month alone Federal prosecutors
have announced multiple convictions for
coveted relief fraud money that was
intended to help keep Americans and
businesses afloat during the depths of
the pandemic being tapped instead by
people committing wire fraud or money
laundering and Congress is also on the
case we owe it to the American people
to get to the bottom of the greatest
theft of American taxpayer dollars in
history the new chair of the house
oversight committee Kentucky Republican
James Comer made covet fraud his first
hearing earlier this month we must
identify where this money went how much
ended up in the hands of fraudsters or
ineligible participants and what should
be done to ensure that it never happens
again justice department Inspector
General Michael Horowitz telling
lawmakers that in the small business
administration's paycheck Protection
Program almost 400 billion dollars was
given out in two weeks 3.6 billion
shouldn't have gone out right away not
saying every one of those would have
been denied but at a minimum there
should have been secondary screening
Democrats emphasizing the legitimate
need for the money you know yes no
program is perfect but it really did
keep afloat the American economy and
made sure that we didn't fall into a
deep deep recession California
Congressman Jimmy Gomez also accusing
Republicans of trying to rewrite history
after supporting trillions in coveted
relief during the Trump Administration
but there is bipartisan concern about it
being stolen so it's a huge range Fox
businesses Grady Trimble the number that
they've kind of been pointing us to at
this point is 191 billion dollars in
unemployment insurance fraud
158 billion dollars in PPP remember the
paycheck Protection Program from the
early days of the pandemic in the cares
act so between those two types of fraud
related to coveted relief the totals
right around 350 billion dollars which
sounds like a huge amount but that's
nothing compared to what some estimates
suggest it could be because that's what
our estimates are based on what they
know what they are suspicious of is that
there's all sorts of fraud that happen
that we are not aware of and that we
haven't cracked down on and it could
total something like a trillion dollars
which is 20 percent of all of the
coveted relief so you know a huge
portion of all of that relief went to
fraudulent causes essentially I know
there have been some cases that
prosecutors are working on around the
country you know charging people with
coveted fraud essentially but what else
is being done is this is Congress trying
to track down kind of the total amount
of fraud are they trying to find more of
it you know what what steps are being
taken yeah so um the the biggest
development over the last couple of
weeks have been coming from two branches
the first is President Biden who said
the Watchdogs are back that he's going
to crack down on the crooks who stole
all of this relief money House
Republicans here on Capitol Hill say
that President Biden hasn't been doing
enough and so they're holding their own
hearings and investigating where all of
this money went and so yes that is the
goal is to ultimately track down you
know where all of it went and hopefully
help us from getting into this type of
situation again with future programs uh
similar to this one what kind of fraud
are we talking about what are some of
the most maybe unusual examples or the
biggest examples that you have found yes
so in one case there there's a man who
was accused of he created this MBE
Capital Partners LLC uh and then was
supposed to be lending out the money but
they're either saying he wasn't lending
the money or he was taking a cut of that
money to the tune of 70 million dollars
and then some other examples are to do
with the unemployment benefits up to 30
million dollars in some cases where
um people were filing false claims for
these uh enhanced benefits
um and so you know those are the extreme
examples but if you even if you just
Google covid fraud you'll see examples
that are much smaller than those in the
millions of dollars just people who were
applying for these enhanced benefits
through somebody else's name or multiple
people's names that they were falsifying
to get the benefits and it could be you
know tens of thousands of dollars all
the way up to you know tens of millions
of dollars are they optimistic meaning
you know Congress and prosecutors
um optimistic of of getting at least
some of these billions back that were
stolen well by some counts they've
already gotten more than a thousand
people either you know in plea deals or
they have been found guilty and
convicted of these crimes you know so
that's progress but it's a small portion
of you know the the amount of money
we're talking about I think it's going
to be hard to get all of this money back
especially if it's a trillion dollars
that we're talking about
um but I I think it's best for them to
be forward-looking and say what can we
learn from the mistakes we made in the
past even if we can't get this taxpayer
money back this time around
Congress started approving coveted
relief bills the same month the World
Health Organization declared a pandemic
the main process the thought process
that stage was just get the money out
the door Fox News senior Congressional
correspondent Chad pogram the economy is
going to be in shambles you're going to
have people on the street you're going
to have people out of jobs you're going
to have probably the worst economic
depression since the 1920s so just get
the money out the door and remember that
they did this in two or three ways you
know there was a very small amount of
money that was approved mostly in the
health realm in very early March of 2020
then about two or three weeks later we
realized just how bad this was and the
world started to shut down so they got
this next tranche of money out the door
which was big and then they had to come
back and reload the paycheck Protection
Program the PPP remember how popular
that was that was basically just saving
you know firms from laying off jobs and
that's where a lot of this fraud seems
to have stemmed from the idea that you
had people who were saying okay I had X
business and some of it was very small
de minimis you know small amounts of
money that they were you know
fraudulently bilking the government out
of in other cases you had people go and
buy luxury homes luxury sports cars and
so that first you know the first you
know few waves of money through 2020
that was all done on a bipartisan basis
so get to 2021 uh this is March and the
Democrats are then in control of the
House and Senate and have a democrat in
the white house and then they passed a
two trillion dollar coveted bill on a
partisan basis I mean this is the the
biggest amount of money that the federal
government has ever shoved out the door
at once and so it should probably come
as no surprise that you're going to have
some of the highest levels of fraud
right I mean if you're talking about the
total amount of covert relief passed in
both the Trump and Biden administrations
I mean it's trillions of dollars yeah
it's about five and a half trillion
million dollars give or take is there a
focus on
one Administration or the other or what
was passed when or are they taking in
Congress a broad look at all of the
coveted relief and all of the fraud no
matter when it happened
well this is what the administration and
and some in Congress are trying to do
but mostly on the Republican side
Republicans are trying to kind of do a
little bit of sleight of hand here
saying okay there's fraud out there
we're having this big conversation about
raising the debt ceiling right now so
what can we call back from people or
what's unspent out there and can we use
that toward deficit reduction well okay
fine let's say that there is several
hundred billion dollars in fraud out
there and they're able to get all of it
back they need to cut about seven
trillion dollars in spending so we on
the high water mark there's you know
four or five hundred billion in fraud
you have to do that about 14 times to
get to your seven trillion so this might
help a little bit but when they talk
about the you know trying to deal with
the national debt and trying to raise
the debt ceiling which is why this
conversation has been merged that's not
going to get you very far just getting
you know coveted money back and that's
something that Republicans frankly from
a policy standpoint are trying to hang
their hat on
what can be done about fraud going
forward Are there specific proposals yet
in Congress to address the issue so this
doesn't happen again
well this came up at a house hearing the
other day where you had the head of the
governmental accountability office Gene
dodaro testify and he was talking about
just the metrics that they were using it
it's hard to keep track of it because
you had so many people being eligible
for this it's very hard to track and and
the problem with that covet bill or the
coveted bills in 2020 is you have to go
back to the mindset we were in crisis I
mean in crisis of the highest order mind
you and so people weren't too hot
worrying about strings being attached
and saying you know how do you decide
who gets what I mean one of the concerns
was that if we don't get this out the
door fast the economy is going to
collapse you know if you got it you know
you thought that might be a death
sentence so they weren't too worried
about putting strings on this it was
just efficiency getting the money out
the door as quickly as possible now you
could have another need for something
else that isn't as big a crisis as covid
and they could you know try to put these
strictures in there but you know this is
what's interesting in following
legislation for many years Lisa is that
legislation is written and it's written
in a very concrete form but there's
always people who are attorneys or
people who are affected by the law
industry or businesses and they figure
out a way to either use the law to their
advantage or get around it
I will say this there is probably far
better accounting now of dealing with
you know just how Federal money is spent
and we spend more of it now and we have
you know 31 you know and a half trillion
dollar debt right now so yeah it's it's
very hard especially when you're dealing
with these gigantic dollar figures just
one other question about the kind of the
bigger picture on Congress right now
are they concerned about covet fraud or
is it more something that can be used
right now in this bigger debate about
spending in the debt limit
I think that there's two things going on
I do think that members are a little
more concerned about covert fraud
because there's probably not going to be
borrowing anything else happen another
big covid Bill but I think the problem
when you look at this is that
Republicans now in the majority in the
house need an issue and they know they
can't cut seven trillion dollars so
that's why Republicans are honing in on
this because this is something they can
attack and also it's a good foil because
you know Republicans ostensibly small
government supposedly want to spend less
money although we can argue about some
of the you know the history with that
frankly with Republican presidents and
Republican congresses
but this is a way for them to say yes
we're against what the administration
did they probably would have less of an
issue the Republicans would have had the
Democrats not pass their own 2.1
trillion dollar coveted bill in March of
2021. that that because then that was
all the Democrats the Democrats had a
majority in the house majority in the
Senate President Biden was new on the
scene and they were able to do it and so
they would have less of an argument now
but this is you know Republicans in the
house trying to find something that they
can you know make into an issue number
one I do think that there is some
genuine concern about that but it's also
we're deep enough past the pandemic now
the worst parts of the pandemic the
people go back and say yeah maybe we
should study some of this Chad program
Fox News senior Congressional
correspondent thank you so much for your
time my pleasure
[Music]
foreign
this is Carol Markowitz with your Fox
News commentary coming up
it was Monday of last week when the
earth quaked in southern turkey and
Northern Syria a powerful magnitude 7.8
jolt as people slept followed by many
aftershocks including one almost as
powerful
but nine days later they're not giving
up Hope
they've been finding survivors in the
rubble of thousands of collapsed
buildings every day
that was one of the rescues yesterday
love it people trapped alive
more than 200 hours imagine that but for
each of those moments of Joy there's a
lot more grief the number of earthquake
deaths is closing in on forty thousand
many more injured or not found eight
girls are missing and no trace of them
so far the debris removal has been
completed in their building and nobody
found anything those girls are that
man's relatives and he says through a
translator families went to the hospital
to give a DNA test but we can't get any
news neither dead nor alive we're just
waiting to find a trace hundreds of
thousands of people are left homeless
some living in tents many need food and
water the situations even more dire in
Syria the Civil War and political Strife
there has made it difficult to get any
Aid in or rescue crews the state
Department's Ned price says the images
of the strategy are profound and we are
working to assist those in need day in
and day out John Morrison is part of
that effort and we caught up with him in
the city of adeyaman Turkey it really is
humbling uh how much power earthquakes
have to destroy what you know the cities
we built he's part of the usaid's urban
search and rescue team from Fairfax
County Virginia not only is it a team of
80 people and six search dogs from
Fairfax County Virginia there's also
another one of the identical size from
Los Angeles County California and so
that's a lot of people and a lot of
things when we come into these cities
that we bring everything that we need so
whether that be our tents our generators
our food our water all of our rescue
equipment all of our medical equipment
we bring with us because we don't want
to be a burden on the local government
that's already dealing with a crisis of
their own so to transport all of that
and all people is a logistical Challenge
and so we arranged or we had arranged uh
several buses along with several tractor
trailers that moved all of this
equipment our trip from incirlik Air
Base to adirama it took us about 12
hours a lot of it it could erode damage
certain Bridges were unavailable and so
they had to be rerouted around and just
traffic uh you know people trying to get
to either help in this area or get out
from this area it complicates a lot of
the situation that 12-hour ride you must
have seen a lot of just horrible stuff
yeah it's traveling through all of those
cities as you get here and you sort of
have to assess how the collapses have
happened and we start doing our work the
second we start seeing those buildings
of how they've collapsed here uh it's
probably very similar to how they're
collapsing in other cities so you're
doing a sort of reconnaissance as you go
and most of us are firefighters and
we're very used to when the call comes
out you sort of get that adrenaline dump
and able to go straight to work so you
get there and you set up your base and
then what so actually while we're
setting up our base we're actually
sending out what we call our Recon teams
and what they do is they're uh usually a
four-person crew that consists of an
officer sort of a team leader an
engineer a dog handler and a search
specialist and they're going out and
they're trying to do what we call Triage
going through the city and trying to
find can we find anybody that's a that's
a currently alive can we hear them the
dogs will run over the Breville pile and
see if they can detect Hue and scent and
also capturing okay we don't know that
somebody's alive in this building but we
don't know that somebody isn't and we
know that people are missing and so we
start categorizing all of that so we can
do the most good for the most people but
you had to have people on the ground
telling you hey we've been we've been
hearing voices from this building or
from this area exactly and the people
here are our best sorts of of
intelligence since we have translators
that usaid provided for us uh and so
that they allow us to interface with the
local community who really guide us on
you know this is the building you need
to focus on uh and and that allows us to
prioritize our work sites but now it's
more than a week
we did here on Tuesday some more people
rescued alive that's more than 200 hours
that's amazing I mean that has to almost
be at the at the at the limit of how
much people can survive there's a lot
that goes into the survivability profile
of a victim whether they're pinned in a
structure uh meaning that the structure
is on top of them and they can't move
because it's pinning their leg down or
whether they're entombed how healthy
they were before the earthquake how much
room they have to maneuver around
the earthquake happened very early in
the morning so we look at residential
structures where people were sleeping
maybe they had betting that's keeping
them a little bit warm and obviously
gets warmer inside the base of the
structure than it would be outside do
they have access to food and water all
those things play into that
survivability profile and we're still in
rescue mode we intend to be in rescue
mode until we're told otherwise by the
Turkish authorities but in this case you
know we we're trying to get to the most
deeply in tuned people now that's what
our team specializes in uh by the time
we get to a place like this typically
most of the people that are lightly
trapped or on the top floor of a
collapsed building have been rescued by
by local authorities and so we are
focusing on those void spaces that are
underneath big heavy concrete buildings
you talked about the dogs
how far down can a victim be for the dog
to still
be able to pick up the scent it really
depends and that goes to how enclosed
the space is that the victim is sort of
breathing in and their scent is
permeating in and once that scent builds
up it may come out in very different
places in the building and so we use the
dogs as one tool out of many to sort of
locate the hey there's a live or
somebody that was recently alive uh
victim in this in this section of the
building or in this area and then we'll
use our listening devices and our
cameras to hone in on exactly where that
victim may be and then our rescue
Specialists will get in there and make
access to the victim and remove them
dogs they can differentiate right
between somebody who's dead and somebody
who is still alive in the scent right
absolutely correct and the dogs we bring
with us are live fine dogs uh for these
missions we do bring human arranged
detection dogs with us for some domestic
missions but for international it's
solely the the live fine dogs that we
bring it has to be delicate though to
get some to extract someone from deep
down I imagine they're the structure is
not very safe and if you do something
here it could lead to a collapse there
right it's it's uh for lack of a better
term a high stakes game of Jenga a
little bit uh we bring our Structural
Engineers with us they're specifically
trained on collapsed building
engineering along with people that
specialize in heavy rigging so working
with local crane operators to lift some
of these slabs off the ground or off the
top level of the building so that we can
more quickly get into these void spaces
underneath the building so you're
exactly right when one of these slabs
gets lifted off the building moves when
you step on a piece of rubble the whole
building can can sort of move with you
so we were very cautious safety is a
incredibly top priority of ours and we
want to make sure that we're not getting
hurt and contributing to the problem we
want to be able to help since you've
been there your team
you how many people do you think you
have rescued from the rubble
you know we've assisted a lot of teams
here uh our teams sold ourselves have
not rescued anybody yet
a lot of these sites have a lot of
rescue teams on them and so we've
certainly helped a lot of the local
teams which is a lot of our goal is to
support the local responders uh and be
able to provide our capacity whether
they need the technical expertise of our
rigging Specialists or rescue
Specialists or the search to back up one
of their canine hits for our doctors to
provide medical advice we're here to
help in any capacity we can have you had
people say that we still hear something
in the rubble
we have we're working active piles right
now and you know it oftentimes it's it's
chasing it's chasing stories of somebody
that said that they heard something or
somebody said that somebody else heard
that they heard something and so you
kind of have to do your best guess and
figure out if it's a possibility of
search and we go into these buildings
and do our best and try and locate all
of these victims as best we can
meanwhile the survivors who are
desperate to find someone are they just
standing there watching what's it like
it's you know it well I think one of the
things that struck me most about this
and this has happened in other disaster
as well as the resiliency of the
population you know people are opening
their storefronts in the in the
buildings and still stand and they're
driving around and trying to get back to
some semblance of normalcy and when
we're working on work sites they're
offering us food and water and it really
is sort of humbling a little bit to you
know be here in a disaster helping
respond and somebody's offering you
something that they have limited
quantities of because they know that
we're trying to help and that is really
moving and it's one of the things that I
take away from this most
people who were left homeless some of
them are intense right they I mean I've
seen so many stories of a lack of food
or not much food or water and there's a
lot of people in different parts of the
region who have nothing
yeah and they they may not want to live
back in their homes that they know are
damaged for fear of an Aftershock so
it's certainly something that you know
ngos and the Turkish authorities are
going to have to respond to and and help
with but yeah it's certainly uh
certainly the case
there's a lot of anger that our reports
that people are upset about the
government or also developers who may
have cut Corners in constructing
buildings can you tell when you get
there that certain buildings were not
necessarily built very well
not not necessarily I mean the power of
these earthquakes when they get up into
the upper sevens and above it really can
damage the best built buildings so
that's not something we look at uh we
just sort of take the building for the
way it is right now as a rebel pile and
how it's how it can affect us with our
rescues and and go to work
how cold you mentioned at night it can
be how cold has it been at night time
for people who are potentially still
trapped alive
uh it's in the 40s during the day it's
been the 20s at night hypothermia is
certainly something we're ready to to
treat for if we come upon a patient with
warm IV bags and additional blankets and
everything else and our doctors are
specifically ready to treat for that
Crush syndrome and anything else they
may find evicted with how bad is this
scene versus others you've been to can
you rank it it's it's comparable to some
of the worst uh you know I was in along
with many other members of our team were
in Haiti in 2010 uh where where hundreds
of thousands of people were killed
um uh we have team members that are here
today that were back in Turkey in 1999
for the earthquakes that were there
um so this is certainly a a disaster
turkey has a robust search and rescue
program within its National capacity but
when you start getting to disasters of
this scale it really overwhelms the
resources and that's why they've called
for international assistance and we were
honored to come help
John Morrison with the usaid's
international Urban search and rescue
team from Fairfax County Virginia in
adeyaman turkey at the moment rescuing
people thank you so much for joining us
no problem thanks for having me
[Music]
I'm Gianna jalosi if Valentine's Day
reminded you that you're unlucky in love
there may be one way to bump up your
chances of getting hit with Cupid's
arrow between now and next Valentine's
Day posing with a pet for your dating
profile pic singles who included photos
of themselves posing with a pup on their
dating profile were more likely to find
a match according to a recent poll of
British adults commissioned by guide
dogs a non-profit organization that
provides guide dog services two-thirds
of people admitted that they're more
likely to match with someone if their
dating profile includes a picture of a
dog 6 in 10 people say they believe
owning a dog is a good sign that a
person is ready to settle down in a
committed relationship people also
presume dog owners to be more social
active and empathetic half of those
polls even said they would borrow a
family or friends dog for a photo shoot
to bolster their dating profile a
separate study conducted by one Poll for
the brand world's best cat litter
recently found the majority of
respondents said they'd be more
interested in someone if their dating
profile included a photo of themselves
cuddling a cat the study polled a
thousand Americans who own cats and a
thousand who don't and found feline
parents were slightly more likely to be
involved in a relationship than non-cat
owners and four in ten people have gone
home with a potential date specifically
to meet that person's pet for the Fox
News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
for the latest news and information from
Fox News listen and download the Fox
News hourly update on your time the
trending stories you need anytime you
want it listen and download now by going
to foxnewspodcasts.com trade and review
the Fox News rundown on Apple podcasts
or wherever you listen it's time for
your Fox News commentary Carol Markowitz
what's on your mind I hold grudges
against companies we don't wear Nike
because the company embraced
america-hating former quarterback Colin
Kaepernick and for a family with two
immigrant parents blessed to be
Americans we cannot abide this I stopped
using Gillette products when their ad
tore into boys and men as angry possible
rapists and our family canceled a trip
to Disney World last year after the
company inserted itself into the
political debate over Florida's parental
rights law
Manhattan Institute senior fellow Chris
Ruffo showcased leaked videos from
inside the company openly discussing
quote adding queerness into children's
programming barring Disney from our
lives didn't feel great this is a
storied American company its success is
the epitome of the American dream I
wanted a path back to being a Disney
family and looked for signs that it had
learned its lesson Disney was quiet
after the leak and went on to replace
its CEO its point of Silence on
political issues led me to believe it
was changing for the better so when I
was invited to speak at a Conference
held at Disney World last weekend we
made the call to go as a family and take
our kids to the parks we arrived at the
hotel late and while my husband and I
checked in the kids watched a TV in the
lobby I remember the show from when I
was little my still little
seven-year-old exclaimed it was the
three Caballeros his favorite as I
looked up the year the film was made
1944 I discovered that Disney had
inserted a disclaimer before the film
that notes quote this program includes
negative depictions and or mistreatment
of people or cultures these stereotypes
were wrong then and are wrong now rather
than remove this content we want to
acknowledge its harmful impact learn
from it and Spark conversation to create
a more inclusive future together end
quote the disclaimer also appears before
films like Aladdin Dumbo and Peter Pan
it's another attempt by Disney to
placate the woke critics it's not a
coincidence that while the failing
streaming service tries to be ever more
woke the Parks have somewhat resisted it
but not entirely we learned in the
leaked videos that Disney no longer uses
ladies and gentlemen at the parks lets
someone feel they don't fit into either
of those categories and like all
attempts to be gender neutral women get
erased completely the bibbidi-bobbidi
boutique where little girls get their
hair and makeup done to become
godmothers in training is now using the
more inclusive fairy Godmother's
apprentices can't let anyone know girls
exist walking around the parks with an
eye on what the vocal Target next is an
exercise in finding problematic issues
everywhere Disney World bathroom signage
at The Parks still has depictions of
dresses for girls and pants for boys
uh-oh It's a Small World uses the same
stereotypical depiction the various
cultures that Disney has informed us are
unacceptable the Hall of Presidents has
much that it chooses not to depict about
each man there is no pacifying the
rabbit left and the sooner Disney learns
this the better we had loved the Disney
parks and past visits those of us still
hoping that Disney can reverse course
lose a little of that hope every time
the company does something clearly bad
for its business we may think of Disney
as too big to fail today but plenty of
huge companies have collapsed after
taking a wrong turn Disney is taking
such a turn today despite its prevalence
wokeness is deeply unpopular in America
they're loud but they're nowhere near
the majority Disney is running out of
time to see the light and go back to
Walt Disney's pro-america pro-child
Vision that we all had known and loved
or will be telling stories about a great
American company that once existed but
fell for the wolf virus and was killed
by it this is Carol Markowitz columnist
at the New York Post at foxnews.com
foreign
and now stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
listen ad free on FOX News podcasts Plus
on Apple podcast and Prime members can
listen to the show ad free on Amazon
music and for up to the minute news go
to foxnews.com
I'm Guy Benson join me weekdays at 3 P.M
Eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the Fox News app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com